who's the greatest wrestler of all time
greatest in-ring performer of all time
is Brett the Hitman Hart what's the
difference in Ring versus well there's
you know there's many facets to the art
form a lot of people are great on the
mic but they're not so great once they
get in the ring a lot of people have all
the uh the Showmanship and stuff but
then they're not necessary it's a
wonderful package but then they get to
the ring or they open their mouth and
there's nothing going on so who's the
greatest in-ring performer I think the
greatest in ring is Bret Hart I don't
think there's anyone better than than
Brett the Hitman Hart uh uh what makes
them so good
well he I think I had an action figure
of him okay in Russia and we didn't know
what the hell that was oh sure yeah it
was just a guy in pink tights uh he
everything makes sense every single
thing is rooted in the thing that just
happened and everything that he does is
to set up what he's going to do uh they
call it and I'm just a wrestling nerd
but the wrestlers I guess call it ring
psychology
um the things that you have to do to to
make it seem like you're you're
suffering or you're coming from behind
or whatever and then also just the
physicality of it he does it at a he
would do it at a 100 miles an hour and
never hurt anybody uh although
you know I I also love uh the every you
know the greatest wrestler of all time
everyone says and they're right it's
Rick Flair Nature Boy Ric Flair everyone
says this yeah I think if you know what
you're talking about
um because he's the best on the mic he's
the he's also incredible in the ring and
then for me the sentimental favorite
which we've actually on duty Chad had
sort of a uh Charlie rose-ask interview
with me about this my fascination with
Hulk Hogan because to me just he was
Superman I was a little kid and I saw
him and that's imprinted but yeah see
this is like asking me who my favorite
child is right so uh The Rock when The
Rock was yeah I mean the Rocks the rock
yeah yeah I mean Hulk Hogan is um
he's the weirdest one right for me from
the outside super weird that I don't
know what what that is exactly it's
everything's weird about him yeah he's
got the ball head like he would proudly
have this bald head with long hair the
handlebar mustache in this ketchup and
mustard you know tights which he says he
credits McDonald's with the tights he
literally does he says that the the red
and yellow came from Angelo poffo who's
Randy Macho Man Savage and Lanny paffo's
dad who's a wrestler and a promoter he
said that he saw him wearing yellow and
you know he's a Tampa guy so he had that
brown skin and the hair and everything
so he's like oh that's what I want to do
and also the brand recognition of like
well I should do it like McDonald's
literally and he's a big you know
swollen muscular uh guy with tan Brown
skins screaming at me to eat my vitamins
and stuff when I'm eight years old that
was extremely uh yeah he's like Superman
I but I know there's a person behind
that guy yeah you know what do you mean
like uh he's Terry boleta the dude who
you know
does whatever the [ __ ] he does with his
life you know what I mean yeah
complicated life yeah I guess to be him
yeah yeah maybe you should change the
the dudes the uh colors to Yellow right
red and yellow it's currently orange and
um
boy sky blue yeah it's like a nice sky
blue